hello and welcome to this video playing
your shake here with black yeah this is
one of the guys where I have no coins to
one out of seven and it's the same
picture every game he's playing quickly
tricky stuff and that blonde or
something we'll see what happened in
this game try to be quick m and this
reti opening there are many possible
setups I just I just choose one and try
to do that quickly these six tries to
play b5 at some point and also rooks is
seven as a move and then Queen eight but
it's got default also make sure there
are a couple of options why can go 91 in
such a position or reform
okay how to do it I cannot move that
night yeah that's bad d7 right yeah i
would i would prefer whites position
here white is a bit better I think okay
would really like to play b5 somehow but
won't be that easy night f4 maybe nor
ever a foursome is also a way to play
this position go form porn porn
expansion his rooks are not ideal for
that though they usually are no F 181
and not not like this which is not
saying that but he places bad or
anything it's just that it is often
somewhat differently um somewhat
differently played her wide I tried to
be reasonably quick because i know that
i had my my issues with the time against
him and one idea here could be to
reroute the d7 night like to see six
that looks like a reasonable idea 95 is
an interesting move here I cannot take I
think because this now yeah probably not
because he's seven hangs at the end like
Ed 5ed 5 and the bishop hangs but 95 I
probably not relevant ok so Bishop back
I guess I'm kind of scared on that long
diagonal so let's retrieve the bishop
okay where are you going 50 I don't know
okay not quite sure yeah the move B 5 is
really desirable to open up the
queenside okay so okay I see now night
at five he wants to take the 95 mm okay
I didn't really understand that concept
interesting very interesting yeah I have
to Jasmine no no shoot would be five
yeah 96 it's that happening no doesn't
okay let's play the move that I had
prepared on a normal ya know I guess 90
on I can actually take with the rook for
90 95 195 immediately this is an
interesting idea actually let's do it
first take that good square and then
take on b5 it's possible prevent 93 and
then things like that that's it's
probably a good move and I can go night
here or is that too fancy if I try that
but I don't see a particularly great
mover i think i will get back the pawn
anyway on b5
can go back to you forward that's not
really having any any point
okay see for no one not really dealing
too much so I'm taking this yeah okay so
you would like to take I guess 194 rupee
3s MSO move
okay let's let's do this
KD 4d for yes we should be too ok let's
idea I don't get it let's go here what
does he want to do like Bishop to b6
takes takes
ok
Jeff hmm interesting check I just got
[ __ ] on the sixth-ranked huh I forgot
about that I wanted to go look be one
now
hmm that's rather stupid time morning
okay check and that's at Phelps I didn't
want to move that very stupid check and
I clearly played this a bit too
ambitious Lee check
what does he win at the end here after
this is God's he's got that bloody King
at each seven here ah stupid drunk fat16
and 73 362 no I'm just in time yeah this
is a draw buddy Gras honored come on
this is the deadest draw ever with the
Jeep on check check check check check
it's a repetition energy point is
especially dad we can just stay on the
eighth-ranked huh now I got a bit too
ambitious around him I can I can just
draw by sitting and I group b 6 and
shuffle but this is a bad idea I wanted
I totally totally forgot that he has to
check on the sixth-ranked I wanted to do
this and and do something active but
he's got a check and this can only heard
me I was a bad idea I think he I can I
can just stay like would be six or yeah
what be six probably has the check on
the six rangas is coming yeah I think
yeah I think yeah this position out of
the opening was certainly a bit better
but I felt at least that I defended this
reasonably well here b5 isn't it's the
counter play again going back him and
her yeah yeah this was supposed
something that I really saw very lady m
that he has the square now so I had to
go back but um yeah Quincy to Jenny
there were alternatives but now i get b
5 in it i should be
okay I believe I think this was a was a
decent move not I mean something like
this I'm he s 93like takes takes and
this is coming is better i get b 5
anyway yeah i think that was a pretty
clean way of equalizing like this yeah i
think the logical outcome is a draw just
with the rupee six I could have taken
actually and played this but it's
probably still at wrong
no it's probably still check check check
so should be a draw even though I can go
see for him check yeah I know I just I
just went I just went to be crazy with
this and this might lose just might
might lose it actually like like them
that that it loses g5 also could have
checked in at five this is scarce
chances given as winning by the computer
and f5 check yeah this looks awfully
past passive but I simply don't have a
way to activate the rook without losing
all the pawns know this is probably lost
and this chain might also be lost but
here the right just at least chances I
are okay oopsie eight was winning this
is a draw this was winning here check
check this okay check check okay nice
but here we are drawing yeah yeah i just
went further for the clear draw yeah I
first I was afraid that check that loses
because it's a check but I'm just in
time of course like this this and it's
at all yet here I mean I don't have to
give up the pawn on d4 but this is the
cleanest the clean is strong yeah I can
just shuffle on the eighth-ranked it's
so late
and shows that engine still have issues
there without table-based stockfish
possesses Azaz plus 1.3 which is quite
funny it's just totally dead you just
don't get have to shuffle on the
eighth-ranked white is no way forward
okay thanks for watching